welcome to the presentation on functions
functions are something that when i
first learned it it was kind of like i
had a combination of i was one confused
and at the same time i was like well
what's even the point of of learning
this so hopefully
at least in this introduction um lecture
we can get at least a very general sense
of what a function is and and why it
might be useful
so let's just start off with just the
overall concept of a function a function
is something that
you can give it an input and we'll start
with just one input but actually you can
give it multiple inputs
you give a function an input let's call
that input x
right
and you can view
a function as
i guess a bunch of different ways you
can do it um i don't know if you're
familiar with the concept of a black box
a black box is kind of a box you don't
know what's inside of it but if you put
something into it
like this x and let's call that box
let's say the the function is called f
then it'll output
what we call f of x
now i know this this terminology might
seem a little confusing at first but
let's make some
i guess let's define what's inside the
box in different ways let's say that the
function was
let's say that f of x
is equal to
x squared plus 1.
then if i were to say what is f of
let's say what's f of 2
right well that means we're taking 2 and
we're going to put it into the box
right and i want to know what comes out
of the box
when i put 2 into it
well inside the box we know we we do
this to the input we take the x we
square it and we add 1. so f of 2 is 2
squared which is 4 plus 1
which is equal to 5.
i know what you're thinking you're
probably like well sal this just seems
like a very convoluted way of
substituting x into an equation and just
finding out the result and
and i agree with you right now but as
you'll see a function can become kind of
a more uh general thing than just an
equation for example let me say
let me actually actually not let me not
erase this
let me let me define a function as this
f of x
is equal to
x squared plus 1
if x is even
and it equals
x squared minus 1
if x is odd
now notice this would have been
this is something that we've never
really seen before this isn't just
what i would call an analytic expression
this isn't just you know x plus
something squared it's we're actually
saying depending on what type of x you
put in we're going to do a different
thing to that x
so let me ask a question what's f of 2
in this example
well
if we put 2 here it says if x is even
you do this one if x is odd you do this
one well 2 is even so we do this top one
so we'd say 2 squared plus one well that
equals five
but then what's f of three
well if we put the three in here
we'd use this case because three is odd
so we do three squared minus one f of
three is equal to 8.
so notice this was a little bit more
i guess you could even say abstract or
unusual than this case
i'm going to keep doing examples of
functions and i'm going to show you how
general this idea can be
and if you get confused i'm going to
show you that
the actual function problems you're
going to encounter are actually not that
hard to do i just want to make sure that
you at least get exposed to kind of the
general idea of what a function is
you can view almost anything in the
world as as a function um
let's say that there is a
a function called sal
in case you don't know that's my name
right
and i'm a function
let's say that if you were to um
if you were to
let me think if you were to give me food
what do i produce
right so what is sal of food
right
so if you input food into sal
what will sal produce well i won't go
into some of the things that i would
produce but
i would produce
i would produce
videos
i would produce math videos if you gave
me food
math videos
right
i i'm just a function you give me food
and and maybe actually maybe i have
multiple inputs maybe you gave me a food
and a computer
and i would produce math videos for you
right
and maybe you
are a function
i don't know your name i i would like to
but i don't know your name and let's say
if i were to input
math videos
into you
then you will produce
let's see what would you produce if i
gave you math videos you would produce
a's on test
a's on math tests right
is on your math test hopefully hopefully
you're not taking someone else's math
test right so it's interesting if you
give well let's let's let's take the
computer away let's say that all sound
needs is food which is kind of true
so if you put food into sal
sal of food he produces math videos
right
and then if i were to put math videos
into you
then you produce a's on your math test
right
so let's let's think of an interesting
problem what is
you
of sal
of food
i know this seems very ridiculous but i
actually think we we might be going
someplace so we might be getting
somewhere with this idea
well
first we would try to figure out what is
sal of food we already figured out if
you put food into sal
salad food is equal to math videos so
this is the same thing as you
of
oh sorry you that's y-o-u
i'm trying to confuse you you of
math videos right
and i already determined we already said
well if you put math videos into the
function called you or you know whatever
your name might be
um then it produces a's on your math
test so that u of math videos equals a's
on your math test
so you of sal of food
will produce a's on your math test
and notice i mean we just said what
happens when you put food into sal
you know it it this could be a very
different outcome if you put like if you
replace food with um let's say poison
right because if you put poison into sal
sal of poison
not that i would recommend that you did
this
sal of poison would equal
um
would equal
death no no i shouldn't say something so
no no no no i uh well you you get the
idea there wouldn't there wouldn't be
math videos
anyway
let me move on
so with that kind of uh i'm not so clear
whether that would be useful um
example with the food and the math
videos
let's do some actual problems using
functions
so if i were to tell you that i had one
function
called f of x
is equal to x
plus 2
and i had another function said
g of x
is equal to
let's say
x squared minus 1.
if i were to ask you what
g
of f
of 3 is
well the first thing we want to do is
evaluate what f of 3 is right
so if you if you you the 3 would replace
the x
so f of 3 so f of 3
is equal to 3 plus 2 which equals
5 right
so g of f of 3 is the same thing as g
of
of 5 right because f of 3 is equal to 5.
sorry for a little bit of messiness
right
so then what's g of 5 well then we take
this 5 and we put it in in place of this
x right
so g of 5 is 5 squared 25 minus 1
which equals
24.
so g of f of 3 is equal to 24.
hopefully that gives you a taste of what
a function is all about and i really
apologize if i have either confused or
scared you with um the sal food slash
poison math video example but in the
next set of
presentations i'm going to do a lot more
of these examples and i think you'll get
the idea of at least how to do these
problems that you might see on your on
your math test and maybe get a sense of
what functions are all about
see you in the next video bye